en la plaza de la ciudad ucranianos
cargando cajas de bombonas de gasolina
caseras siguiendo las instrucciones del
gobierno para defender sus hogares
estos son para hacer cócteles mólotov
esta es la única manera posible de
protegernos a nosotros mismos a nuestros
hijos a nuestros padres y abuelos y a
todos nosotros
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa a
los ciudadanos de litro en el centro de
ucrania organizan una resistencia a poca
distancia los voluntarios se alistan en
masa para unirse a las fuerzas de
defensa territorial y comienzan a
trabajar en las defensas de la ciudad
dejando atrás sus trabajos y familias
entiendo que ahora mismo no debo ser un
simple fisioterapeuta o médico debo ser
un soldado que apunta a nuestro enemigo
con una kalashnikov destruiremos a este
enemigo estoy preparado y mis hijos y mi
mujer también lo están
y hay muchos como el guardias de
seguridad empresarios que ahora prestan
apoyo al ejército ucraniano aunque
algunos nos dicen que han recibido poca
formación y les falta equipo
4 nos han dado algunas armas pero no
tenemos suficientes chalecos antibalas
ni cascos
queremos que nuestros socios europeos y
americanos nos ayuden
aquí llegan algunos suministros no es
material militar sino cualquier cosa que
los residentes locales pueden conseguir
para ayudar al esfuerzo bélico de
ucrania
los voluntarios se apresuran a organizar
frenéticamente las donaciones de ropa
mantas y alimentos que se enviarán a los
soldados voluntarios y hospitales
estamos preparados y sabemos que rusia
no esperaba que nuestra nación se
levantará tan rápida y activamente tanto
la gente corriente como los actores
cantantes y directores de cine han
dejado sus casas y están ayudando a la
defensa territorial
mientras las tropas rusas avanzan los
ciudadanos de esta ciudad están haciendo
un esfuerzo siendo un símbolo de la
resistencia popular